[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Shazam Black Adam
vs. Superman movie video The Rock just
did this big announcement video on his
Instagram where he talked about what's
going on with the movie he's been a lot
of that video talking about the Superman
character so I'll play that clip then
I'll explain what's going on because it
is the path to Henry Cavill coming back
as Superman inside the DC EU the rock
even commissioned boss logic to do some
Superman versus Black Adam art when he
was pitching the studio on what the
Black Adam movie would be so it sounds
like he's been thinking about Black Adam
vs. Superman for a long time so if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a new Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave all your black adam vs superman
predictions on the video here's that
clip of the rock talking about the Black
Adam movie in talking about Superman vs
Black Adam the first question is how
excited am I to play Black Adam I am so
excited to play Black Adam so excited so
pumped up so ready so focus so I don't
have the vocabulary of times to say
excited I am about black Adam as many of
you know black Adam is a super villain
from the world of the DC Universe and
this project again as many of you know
because I know you've been following it
intensely following it along through the
years Black Adam has been with me for
over 10 years now and that gives you an
idea of how passionate I am about this
project how passionate our 7 bucks is
about this project Warner Brothers New
Line Cinema's DC they have been so
incredibly supportive over the years I
mean this is over 10 years in 2008 is
when we first started talking about this
though it has required a patient by all
of us as partners and you know I'm a
much different man and an actor than I
was 10 years ago
and I felt 10 years ago that even then
10 years ago I just wanted to wait till
for the timing to feel right and it
feels like now the men that I've
you know I'm able to bring a little bit
of my own life lessons and philosophies
and ingrain them in the DNA of this
character and as those of you who
followed the mythology of Black Adam and
in the comics which is millions of you
and for those of you don't know Black
Adam there's a lot of deep layers to
Black Adam he is a man who is his
Constitution and his wiring and his
makeup is one of resolve and it is one
of a boundless anchor if you will and he
started off as a slave there's there's
some dark elements to Black Adam and you
know one of the things that I really
loved about the character of Black Adam
is that he was blessed by the Wizards by
the gods of four powers and his powers
equal that of Superman which
automatically you know makes him
intriguing but he was also bestowed a
equalizing power and that equalizing
power is Magic which is certainly
Superman's weakness and I'm not I'm not
setting up a showdown between Black Adam
and Superman maybe down the road but
right now I'm just giving you guys
context for those of you who don't know
on how powerful Black Adam is and one of
the most interesting things about Black
Adam to me is the fact that when you
compare him to Superman Superman
believes in truth and justice and
everyone gets their due process even the
bad guys who've done a lot of damage at
harm to the world and Superman believes
in bringing them to justice and then if
justice is served properly the bad guys
go to jail in the case of Black Adam who
is a super villain who then became a
antihero
by the way our first version of Black
Adam is going to be his origin stories
so we're going to understand where he
came from as he made his way to becoming
black Adam but the difference is you
know with black Adam a few wrong black
Adam and
wrong his family if you harm his family
or have you harmed his people then he's
not going to send you to jail he's gonna
rip you in half literally bang he's
gonna rip you an ad it's kind of dark
but again that is that's the core of who
black Adam is so I'm very excited about
Black Adam our director is going to be
JAMA Colette's Dara who has been working
intensely over the past year he has a
great vision a tremendous vision for a
black Adam
JAMA Colette's Dara just directed myself
and Emily Blunt in Jungle Cruise which
will be out this summer in July maybe
hopefully we'll see if we're going to
come out this summer it all depends we
will continue to gauge our global
situation and we'll see Lauren Shearer
who is our director of photography as a
few of you may know Lawrence was just
nominated for an Academy Award for his
brilliant photography in the Joker so we
are assembling our Black Adam team and
we're bringing it all together and I'm
very very excited about it so as you
could see the rock is trapped inside his
house because of the virus like a lot of
other people in the United States so
that's why you spending so much time
talking about the Black Adam movie
they're getting ready to shoot it
starting in August later this summer
which does seem like it's in the safety
zone and they'll be okay to start
filming on time as you saw in the teaser
video that I put at the beginning of
this the movie's supposed to come out at
the end of next year so they still have
plenty of time but here's the thing
about Black Adam vs. Superman he spends
a lot of that video talking about the
first Black Adam movie and says that
Superman is not gonna be in the first
movie he's like I'm not trying to tease
Superman in this first movie what he's
saying right now is the Black Adam vs.
Superman would be one of the Black Adam
sequels after the character has
transitioned into present-day because
the first movie tells his backstory
thousands of years ago that a little of
it takes place near present-day because
they had the Justice Society so it's
kind of set in the past but not that far
in the past in pers a curry Levi the
plan for the Black Adam in Shazam
franchises right now is that they'll do
the Black Adam movie next year then
right after that they'll do Shazam -
they'll set up a cameo for Black Adam at
the end of that teasing him in Shazam 3
which will be the full blown Shazam Lee
vs. Black Adam
then at some point in that timeline
maybe before Shazam three or after
Shazam three that's when they would do
Black Adam - Black Adam versus Superman
the reason why that movie is the key to
Henry Cavill coming back as Superman
inside the DC EU is because of an
interview that amy adams did recently
talking about the future of her Lois
Lane character people asked her if she
wanted to continue she said she would
love to be Lois Lane in new DC movies
but she didn't think that it would ever
happen because her Lois Lane is tied to
Henry calvo's version of Superman so
much and she Amy Adams had heard
recently within the studio that they
were planning on going in a different
direction with the Superman character
which means recasting Superman with a
totally different actor for another
Superman movie same thing that they just
did with Ben Affleck's Batman recasting
with Robert Pattinson in Matt Reeves
Batman movie not being connected to any
of the other Batman movies with Ben
Affleck I've done a couple videos for
the Batman movie I'll link those at the
end of this Henry Cavill has already
made it clear that he wants to continue
playing Superman so it sounds like the
studio just does not want to make a Man
of Steel movie with him but the rock is
powerful enough to demand that they
allow him to use Henry Cavill Superman
in a potential black atom sequel think
of it as black atom saving Henry Cavill
Superman's life within the DC EU but I
love that the rock teased that he's
actually been working on this movie
since 2008 that's when he started
talking to Warner Brothers about playing
the character then within a couple years
of that they started working on
developing a script the reason why it's
taken this long to make the movie is
mostly as The Rock says he just wasn't
there as an actor he didn't feel like he
was good enough and they didn't have the
right story yet but everyone just got
done watching DC do the Joker movie
Joaquin Phoenix the film when all these
Awards made over a billion dollars so
now just feels like the right time to do
a villain movie when he's talking about
the story of the Black Adam movie
obviously he's talking about the origin
but he mentions his family dying his
people dying in conduct in how that
pushes him to break bad so he's implying
that they're going to show you the
actual backstory for this PowerPoint
presentation that the wizard gave to
Billy during the Shazam movie so I'm
guessing a lot of that will take place
really early in the Black Adam movie and
then you'll see him closer to
present-day
fighting the Justice Society black Adam
is a little more hardcore is a film but
I'm not expecting it to be a horror film
not in the way that they're talking
about making dr. strange to a scary MCU
film speaking of the villain connection
to the Joker movie with Joaquin Phoenix
the Black Adam movie is also using the
cinematographer from the Joker movies so
it sounds like they've got a lot of
creative energy that they're using from
the Joker film and using that to enhance
the black atom film which i think is a
good thing but everyone let me know in
the comments what do you think about a
black atom versus Superman film set
sometime later in the timeline after you
have Shazam Lee versus black atom based
on when they're releasing all these
movies the earliest they could do black
atom versus Superman if that's gonna be
a black atom sequel would be 2023 so
it's still a ways off that's like a
couple seasons deep into the Witcher
Netflix so toss a coin to your Witcher
Superman because it actually sounds like
he has a chance of coming back as the
Man of Steel I've got a couple of the
videos I'm working on I'll try to post
those as soon as possible
everyone click here for all the Batman
teaser trailer and Easter egg videos and
click here to learn about what's going
on with Spider Man 3 in the Marvel
Netflix characters coming back thank you
so much for watching everyone stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]